[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday March 29th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Samsung is the world's largest
smartphone maker by shipments but the
smartphone market is in a weird place
sales are down but customers will still
spend on the highest end phones it's
perhaps no wonder then that Samsung is
betting on artificial intelligence to
develop new features for its devices at
this year's mwc formerly World mobile
Congress Samsung EVP Patrick chomay
spoke at the wsj's journal house he
answered questions from our senior
personal Tech columnist Joanna stern
here are highlights from the event
Patrick thank you for joining us what is
Samsung thinking about Ai and is it
really at the top of the list as you're
innovating yes yes definitely it is
called as being a lot of focus on the on
the Voice assistance so we have Bixby
that have been Alexa and others but it's
much more than that for us actually the
biggest application of AI in our device
is in the digital experience in the
camera things like to get the quality of
pictures in low lights that we have I
would encourage you to try what we do is
we combine a series of pictures and with
a neural engine optimize all the noise
the 200 megapixel camera is not just
about having 12 megapixel as a big
number and Detail in low light condition
we can combine four to 16 pixels and
with AI techniques filter out the noise
to get better quality so AI is very very
deeply embeddy enough for that in image
processing in the power management for
example to foresee which app you are
using not using shut them down and
optimize the battery usage it's all over
what about the generative AI space you
mentioned Bixby and I think there's
there's a feeling out there how many
people think and I'm not going to just
we won't focus on Bixby but we'll say
Bixby Siri and Alexa are just the
smartest in the world anyone out there
think they're just super smart all right
how many people out there think chat gbt
and Dolly and stable diffusion are just
incredible
smart
I mean just are at least wowed me too
yeah okay so for years we've sort of
thought okay these voice assistants
they're not so smart no offense to Bixby
now there's this next wave is this the
FI is this really the like realization
that this is what the voice assistants
are going to be and are we going to see
that integration
um I believe we are talking about two
different things the the food I call the
first generation of voice assistants I
was Bixby and others
I think they were conceived on the on a
model which was some kind of brain
assistant human Centric design that
would control all the devices and the
services and the reality is that the
artificial intelligence is much more
distributed but we just said it's in the
the image processing it's in the
applications like Gmail gmaps is in our
own applications so I I think we are
going for a much more distributed vision
and in that Vision the the ah the
generative AI techniques I think they
offer great possibilities but again not
in this kind of centralized way you can
imagine this technology is used in each
and every part of the service area which
rgbt and Bing I've been using Bing a lot
and you are interacting with a computer
you are talking to it in a way that it
is human-like which I think we sort of
all expected you know this is where Siri
and Bixby and Alexa were gonna go
is are you is Samsung looking at using
these Technologies to make that
conversation better on on a phone
absolutely so we as you know we have
great partners and at this third
Microsoft is a partner Microsoft is a
popular Google is a popular which makes
it interesting
so Bixby Bixby is our voice agent
control the phone so it's a very
effective tool to commence things on
your phone not only your phone also we
use it a lot in the connected home come
on your uh Appliance and things like
that so we are very focused on how to
Simply command and Quantum our Samsung
devices by voice uh the the generative
AI techniques is allowing different
things and our expectation is that we
will work without buffers deeply we have
to leverage all the potential you're
able to use Bixby to respond to a call
yeah that's good right tell me how that
works and then I want to talk about the
generative voice part of that so all
that works if you are in this situation
and some Stephanie would call me I would
answer my text I am in the meeting right
now I call you back later my voice will
play back to where in that voice chord
so for now the voice recordings it works
in Korean and English in the Korean
language you can record your own voice
so the The Listener would receive
actually your own voice in English it
will come very soon so we love that
feature it's good but what you're
virtually doing is doing a voice clone
you're making a version of your voice
and then you can type in whatever and
you're going to hear that version of
your voice right yes but it's still
generative AI this is uh fundamental uh
well digital filtering okay we will
capture the tone of your voice and
reproduce that tone so which is quite
different from the full machine learning
generative AI engine so it won't sound
exactly like me it does it does okay so
it will because it will sound like is
that a good idea
that my phone will sound exactly like it
Won't Anyone can type in what I sound
like you decided to only she decided to
but will there be any so say um somebody
decides they want to do a recording of
Tom Cruise on this and their voice will
be Tom Cruise can that is there
restrictions on that but you can do that
today
you can record any boys they are
application on internet to modify the
tune you can do that but this is going
to be on Samsung phones there's more
Samsung phones than probably some of
these uses I think it's based on user
choice I don't see it whatever it's
really I think it's quite fun actually
okay let's shift to talking about VR ar
your partnership Samsung Google and
Qualcomm around headsets and we talked a
little bit about the future but it
sounds like you guys are all three
teaming up to make something what are
you making
hmm yeah that's one today it's a fun
factor of fact maybe you have a picture
you have a phone you can race or they
can say no I don't have a picture yet
but I can tell you what we do the reason
why we announce is we believe it's a
it's a long journey and there is a lot
of work to be done and a characteristic
of our ecosystem is we are open so we
don't do it alone so we are doing a lot
of fundamental work with obviously
Qualcomm and Google on the core
Technologies and finding out the right
experiences but also as we go we are
signaling to a number of ecosystem
players that they should be ready to
develop applications and apps and
services to that ecosystem because we
believe uh when the mixed reality
devices will come in okay we do some
good stuff and we have some good apps
and so does Google and Qualcomm as
technology but the real power comes from
a richer ecosystem there are a lot of
startups and a lot of smaller companies
will innovate if we give them the right
access and if we have enough time
develop on that on that platform and
they also have the confidence that big
companies like Qualcomm and Samsung and
Google are into it for the long term
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you all of you for being here and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign